So why are we interested
in segmentation?
And what do we mean by segmentation?
Well by segmentation obviously,
we're going to segment the image
into a variety of regions.
And the regions that you want to create
depend a little bit on what you're
actually trying to do.
So, there's this general intuition,
and here we point to this work up by
the folks out at Berkeley and
Jitendra Malik, and his group.
They really pushed hard on this.
There's this general view
that if I show you a picture,
like this picture here on the left here,
which has these, bison.
That's what we call them in the States,
or buffaloes, and
we still have them wandering around,
not in Atlanta, but in general.
The idea is that I should be able to,
you know, if I handed that picture off
to a, to anybody and I said, draw
a border around the different objects,
you would get something that looks
kind of like that, all right?
People would segment and, and the, this
segmentation wouldn't all agree, right?
Some people might separate out this
little guy here from the grass but
you can see that this one doesn't.
But in general,
there'd be a good agreement on
where the different elements are.
And this database that's pointed to,
they recorded a whole bunch of
segmentations done by people, and
that can be used to train systems.
Here's just another example taken
from a typical American scene here.
In fact,
it even says that it's in Idaho.
And you can see that the,
the regions that were cut out seemed to
correspond intuitively, what you might
think of as the different object, or
something more along
the lines of different parts.
Another reason you might want to do
this, is you've got some objects,
that are sort of the ones you want to
pay attention to against the background.
And you want to focus on the object,
and not the background.
So, here's some examples referred
to as figure ground segmentation,
which is the pulling out of the,
the figure from the background.
And these typically are done in
things that are moving around.
Here we've got some animals playing.
Here's a strange creature
referred to as a young child.
And the idea is that you'd like to
be able to pull those objects out.
So if you want to analyze,
like we were doing activity recognition,
you want to describe just
the movement of the object.
Another way of thinking about
segmentation, again some work that was
introduced by Malex Group is
this notion of super pixels.
So these two pictures that
you're looking at here,
you can see that everything is sort of
cut up into these little fragments.
And the idea of these fragments,
especially take a look at along around
here, right, is that within those
fragments, everything is sort of the
same, and it's within the same region.
And what that means is, when I think
about further cutting up this picture,
or processing it, I don't have to
think beyond these little regions,
which we'll refer to as, well later
in the literature, as superpixels.
Right, the idea is that I go from
having tens of thousands, or
hundreds of thousands of pixels,
to maybe having hundreds of superpixels.
So that makes the combinatorix much,
easier.
And again, getting these superpixels
is a form of segmentation.
Segmentation extends beyond
just single images of course.
Here we're taking a look at video.
This is actually some work that comes
from here at Georgia Tech done by both
Professor Erfanisa, Jim Raise and
Professor Jim Raise group here.
And there's this ice skater going along.
And the ice skater is being segmented
and it's not always so easy because
here, it's showing you against just
ice but obviously it pulls it out.
And you want to be able
to extract it carefully.